so zlatan who is a
superstar soccer player okay i mean top
10 in the world right now i don't know
if he's top 10 he is probably
one of the most you know or maybe not
today at his prime because right now
he's in his late 30s but
at his prime this guy was a ridiculous
talent coming in everybody's six five
powerful gets in your face he's buzzing
creation yeah okay
is it cool if you've ever seen his
highlight just type in google zlatan
fights
he is a beast of a guy right so he goes
out there and he's a guy that's known
for saying what's on his mind he says
lebron james is a phenomenal of what
he's doing but i don't like it when
people with some kind of status
and they do politics at the same time as
what they're doing
i mean do what you're good at so zlatan
calls out
uh uh lebron james so now lebron james
has to respond back and this is what
lebron james says
he says there's no way i will ever just
stick to sports
um there's no way i will just stick to
sports there's gonna
he's i would never shut up about things
that's wrong
i preach about my people and i preach
about equality social justice racism
systemic voter suppression
things that go in our community because
i was part of my community at one point
and seeing the things that was going on
and i know what's going on still because
i have a group of 300 plus kids at my
school that's going through the same
thing and they need a voice and i'm
and i'm their voice i'm their voice and
i use my platform to
continue to shed light on everything
that may be going on not only in my
community but around this country and
around the world there's no way i would
just ever stick to sports because i
understand how
this platform works how powerful my
voice is
thoughts okay well i come from the same
background that zlatan does and i'm a
huge fan as you can imagine
he's extraordinary as it relates to
soccer but i'm totally annoyed at him
because he has a
huge platform and he does use his voice
to speak up against racism and
he zlatan himself has experienced
tremendous amounts of hatred
because of his ethnic background and has
experienced racism
playing in europe so
i think as such high-profile global
stars
in two respective fields i think it's
incredible to use your voice to speak
out
and speak up about what things that are
really really important to you because
you have all these people across the
world listening to you
um and i feel he just kind of played
into this
um super conservative
in my mind racist
ploy of you know stay in your lane don't
you know
just shut up and dribble which i think
is awful
um he i know from what i read he admires
lebron loves
lebron but i don't think
he should have phrased it
the way he did in that but i also
understand coming from where we come
from particularly in former yugoslavia
when you talk about politics you
put yourself in a really uncomfortable
situation you just
were taught from early age never talk
about it don't talk about politics
keep your mouth shut because you're
gonna get in trouble
one way or another it's almost like you
you associate fear
we're talking about politics and so
he's experienced so much hatred zlatan
has
playing in different fields even like
recently he was playing in belgrade and
there was a huge racist rant they had to
apologize to him and he was
very stoic he just didn't say anything
and kind of like sucked it up so if he's
you think he should respond back
absolutely so when if you have such a
huge platform
and if you believe
in social equality and justice and and
people being at least but what should he
say what should he's like if he's a
player and people
scream stuff at him what should he say
i don't think he should necessarily
respond to a particular person who's
being
ignorant or hateful or racist or
whatever
but i think he should use twitter you
talked about technology
use your voice to say that's not cool
this is
this is what i've experienced and would
you did you see what happened to this
basketball player jeremy lin in the g
league last week did you hear about them
asian names or calling them corruption
so there's two there's two school of
thought here and it's and i
i think at this point it's just
philosophical so to
to to jeremy lane he's playing
basketball one of the opponents calls
him coronavirus because he's from china
say hey coronavirus say coronavirus so
he says i'm experiencing you know racial
slur comments you know people are kind
of saying a coronavirus so they said
who said it he said i'm not going to go
out there and tell anybody on who said
it because i don't want to throw anybody
under the bus
i just want to bring awareness to say
it's not appropriate
and i hear it but it needs to stop but
i'm not going to call anybody up
i thought his approach was actually
very responsive to the high road i like
the way he did it i like the way that he
uh took that and by the way earlier this
year something happened with lebron
at a game at an atlanta game i don't
know which game it was paul when one of
the fans
started shouting at lebron the husband
and him went at it and then they got
kicked out
and then they asked lebron afterwards so
lebron what do you think about what
happened right now he says well listen
i'm just glad the fact that fans are
back because that's fans they scream we
go at it we go back and forth
that is normal that's going to be taking
place so you know
i you know sometimes i wonder if some of
these athletes like zlatan is like
i just don't even want to get into the
political world just to get into the
world yet he has such a big platform
to use it is it right to use it or is it
better to take the michael jordan
approach and say look man i'm just not
getting into politics
that's exactly where i was going with
this is that you know michael jordan set
a precedent
for himself and athletes that he was
going to be apolitical
even in north carolina when i don't know
if it was jesse helms or whoever the
hell it was in north carolina was a
blatant racist
running against a black politician and
people
even as i think his mom and people in
this corner are like you gotta speak up
about this like
these are your people like what's up and
he's like you know what famous
famous quote republicans buy sneakers
too and he just
and he's been for a long time apolitical
and during
the blm and and blue lives matter
movement he donated
you know an equal amount of money to
both sides right lebron james different
character
lbj dgaf uh
lebron james don't give a f you know so
he has a voice he's gonna use it he's
not gonna just shut up and dribble
uh laura ingraham you know called him
out a few years ago and he's like no but
but i thought that was also a dumb
comment she made what do you mean just
shut up
disrespect yeah yeah it's it's it's not
about just shut up and drove i just i
think
like you know i think it's just a
different
level of res i like jordan's approach
i like jordan's approach of what he took
and i do think you talk about
your own but i also think there's an
element of lebron also been divisive
i think i think you're also dividing
america you said you've been polarized
by lebron you've been vocal
i'm not a fan i don't i don't think he's
a uniter i mean all this stuff about
united united united lebron
definitely is not what's different about
what he's doing and what trump's doing
dividing did i say trump's a united no
no no did you hear me at all
category not at all i think lebron and
trump are very similar
mm-hmm i think lebron is playing to
their base i think lebron and trump are
very similar
very similar the only difference is
trump converts lebron doesn't
lebron just gets his own audience but he
doesn't convert trump
used to convert trump is a conversation
no longer because he doesn't have a
platform
if he did he would continue he lost his
platform that's the point
yeah but what i'm trying to tell you is
lebron and trump believe it or not
are very very similar very similar well
jordan
is in a league of his own in the way he
handled media
and the way he did everything jordan
reagan
you know those guys you put in a similar
league of their own
john f kennedy these are in the league
of their own okay
reagan won 49 out of 50 states and even
democrats like the guy
okay john f kennedy even republicans
like them jordan even republicans like
him
you know even when uh jordan and barkley
were once on an oprah winfrey show
you know and they were teasing each
other and barclay actually there wasn't
but they were
the olympics and something they were
playing he says hey
uh uh jordan mike why don't you tell
everybody who'd you vote for
for president none of your business yeah
i know you voted republican
so there is that uh that joke that
barkley would have with him
so but i like the way jordan did it uh
and quite frankly i
you know zlatan is probably sitting
there for zlatan to do this and you go
back to his history
yeah and he made some comments years ago
himself
that he used uh used his own platform he
made some comments saying there was some
comments made about me so he has done it
before
so there's a little bit of a hypocrisy
on zlatan's position as well because
he's
zlatan's like a trump for you to say
don't use your platform to say anything
you can say i disagree with lebron but
you can't say don't use your platform
the guy's gonna use his platform so
lebron can't say whatever he wants to
say if he agrees disagrees
he's earned the right to say whatever he
wants to say there's shots that comes
with it
but he can say whatever he wants to say
i think zlatan's one of those guys that
he's so witty he's so smart he's so good
with the media
that he would actually make a decent
politician later on he would be
entertaining i'm being serious
and and by the way i think he likes
controversy as well so he knows that
everyone's going to be talking about
zlatan if if you know he goes
against do you think there was a little
bit more behind this when he said this
comment you knew that it would get
picked up lebron would exchange now
we're talking about it on the part
totally no no guess who's trending right
now in the past
fyi zlatan played for what team in the
soccer ac milan
yeah and then where did he play in us
okay who else was in l.a at the time
david
lebron james so la you know there's some
stuff you know
these guys are competitive guys you know
when when zlatan came to if you ever
watch him play when he went and played
for galaxy
let me tell you people lost their minds
when this guy played i want to watch
this guy
i was on the grass watches latin play
it's ridiculous watching this guy play
live i mean like an analogy would you
like is he he's charles barkley of
soccer who is he's the lebron james of
soccer with his body because soccer
players are tiny
but he's not lebron james is like the
greatest of all time like stop it
like ronaldo would be lebron please get
this ronaldo or not ronaldo
get him out of this building hey hey hey
hey lebron lebron
jordan's the greatest of all time jordan
would be like a pele that's what i mean
yeah jordan would be like a pele
no what i'm saying let me make ronaldo
would be lbj let me make the analogy
that's a little better for you yes
please
is lebron the greatest human specimen
ever in the game of basketball
outside of shaq physically physically
yeah yeah that's what you're saying
physically
oh he's i'm saying i'm saying iconically
or legendarily
game-wise like he he's he's shaq
okay he's the shack of soccer it's the
best way to put he's the shack of soccer
let me tell you he pushed people around
he elbowed you in the face he slapped
you in the face he punched you he did
everything everything you're not
supposed to do better than zidane
oh league of his own yeah the guy was a
taekwondo black belt
who played soccer so he's known you know
he's a fighter and he's uh
you know he's a survivor he's aggressive
he's very very aggressive so you know
go type in zlatan kicks on youtube see
how he feels
he would destroy a person if he kicked
him i love watching him too by the way
it's just it's it's a persona have you
seen this documentary
i have not seen it okay so the
documentary is a good one because they
record him when he's 17 years old and
he's going with his manager to go
negotiate a big contract
he's about to get a massive contract and
his uh
his manager is getting nervous and
zlatan 16 17 years ago says
get your act together you're acting like
you're scared okay
act like you belong here tell us the 50
year old
he tells his 50 year old manager act
like you belong here why do you look so
nervous act like you've been here 16
17 year old kid telling that to you of
himself in third person yes he does
so yeah you gotta love the guy and then
you go so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody bye